il y a une tempête
qui approche, ça va empirer
avant que la situation ne
s'améliore. Le comté du Delaware est maintenant sous un
avertissement d'inondation
papa Mama's Gone, un meilleur endroit il
nous appelle amen nous continuerons nous avons gardé
notre tradition dans sa pureté nous le faisons
comme ça  que nous l'avons toujours fait, iris est
la plus ancienne, c'est sa responsabilité, maintenant
tu es prêt pour ça, c'est comme ça que ça
marche,
j'ai trouvé quelque chose d'étrange ce matin, je
ne crois pas que ce soient des restes humains, la tempête
a emporté des os tout au long du ruisseau, nous
devons  restez ensemble maintenant, il y a 30
personnes qui ont disparu de cette ville au cours des 20 dernières
années, êtes-vous sûr, doc, je
ne sais pas, et si nous refusions de le faire,
il nous forcerait, n'est-ce pas,
je ne peux pas faire
ça, votre femme a souffert d'une
maladie rare  vous avez faim DG nous en avons
beaucoup merci pour la nourriture que nous
recevons
père Soulevez-nous de ce
monde bénis soient les agneaux car ils sont
son
offrande
amen